[Musique]
jouer au football en étant déficient
visuel c'est tout à fait possible à la
réunion de jeunes sportifs déficients
visuel pratique le sess foot un sport
adapté importé du pays du football le
Brésil depuis 2 ans de jeunes sportifs
de l'association cess fooot runion
s'entraîent et organise des rencontres
aujourd'hui ils jouent contre des
footballeurs voyants qui vont pour la
première fois se priver du sens de la
vue pour jouer un match le jeu se joue à
5 joueurs par équipe quatre non voyants
masqués par un bandeau et un gardien
voyant pour le reste David Warot le
fondateur de l'association briefe
rapidement les jeunes footballeurs alors
aussi une chose aussi importante quand
vous déplacez s ballon vous dites VO voy
qui signifie j'arrive dire c'est une
règle c'est une règle très important
c'est une règle de sécurité pour éviter
le télescopage qu non quand vous n'avez
pas le ballon quand vous avez le ballon
voilà vous dites rien parce y a le
sign quand vous vous déplz déplz vous
dites en esp
ça des questions plus de questions le
mieux est de se jeter à l'au le temps
d'immortaliser la
rencontre il est temps maintenant de
fermer les yeux c'est parti le match
peut démarrer la balle est au
[Musique]
no
pas facile de se repérer dans l'espace
quand on est dans l'obscurité les plus
entraînés prennent l'avantage et
approchent des buts les repères sont
sonores pour marquer l'équipe dispose
d'un guide derrière les
[Musique]
cages fin de la première mi-temps les
joueurs nous donnent leurs premières
impressions ah c'est difficile
l'orientation sans les yeux je vois pas
du tout mes coéquipiers pour faire la
passe c'est c'est vraiment compliqué ah
c'est pas facile on a du mal à se situer
sur le terrain et quand eux ils arrivent
sur eux ça se voit qu'ils sont plus
habitués on sait pas quand est-ce qu'ils
arrivent et on sait pas o si tu n coquip
on arrive pas à faire le passe au-delà
des difficultés techniques ces jeunes
joueurs voyants font l'expérience de se
déplacer sans voir lui c'est un autre
monde en fait c'est un autre monde par
rapport à la réalité quand je joue en
club et du coup ce monde là ben je le
découvre ce matin au chaudron et du coup
ben je prends plaisir avec eux et n pas
facile pous aussi de la vie en général
mais mais que on a l'expérience aussi
sur le terrain pas du tout
nous pratiquer ce sport a des vertus
éducatives il permet de développer des
facultés compensatoires et ainsi
l'autonomie des déficients visuels ben
sur le terrain voyez on se déplace sans
canne on n pas dans la rue donc déjà ça
c'est apprendre à essayer de se repérer
ça aussi ça ça donne confiance déjà moi
j'ai toujours été un passionné de
football donc pour moi avoir la
possibilité de le de le pratiquer le
sport que j'aime tant c'est déjà un réel
plaisir et puis ça me ça me permet aussi
de de Me on va dire entre guillemets de
me dépasser on étant sous bandau avec un
ballon avec un clochette dedans
ben comment ça il du encore plus les
oreilles train pour développé en fin de
compte et ah me en terme niveau sportif
même
ouais c'est moi trouve que il est comme
football normal c'est juste qu'il joue
avec un bandeau un ballon un clochette
dedans après c'est juste l'adaptation en
fin de compte ça me permet de développer
un sport pu que rester chez ch premier
bon ça ça m'a permis mieux de travailler
l'autonomie avant puisquon apprend le
trajet de bus que du déplacement donc ça
m'a permis de r rentrer dans un sport
organiser des rencontres avec les
joueurs de football classique c'est
aussi pour les défics visuells un moyen
de passer un message à propos de leur
handicap il y a des actions qu'on a mené
déjà depuis 2013 on des actions déjà de
sensibilisation lors des centes aéré
dans des écoles avec des clubs de des
associations sportives des clubs de
football traditionnel la lig de football
on a fait aussi une action avec le pôle
expoir avec les jeunes du Pôle Espoir on
a fait aussi des actions avec des
joueurs pro on a eu dernièrement Thomas
fontaine qui qui joue à auxer qui a fait
la finale finale de la Coupe de France
on fait pas mal d' action toute l'année
qui permet de nous faire connaître et
qui permett aussi de considérer les
jeunes C si futeux comme d'abord des
sportifs et non comme des personnes
handicapé en fait problème c'est que une
personne visuelle des fois déf visuelle
c'est des fois c'est c'est pas bien vu
mais pas que déf visuel d'autres d'utres
handicap donc nous en fait ce qu'on veut
c'est de montrer qu'on des personnes
humaines et qu'on est capable de faire
des choses mais peut-être autrement mais
on est capable de faire des choses C si
rignon s'inscrit dans une démarche
d'ouverture de rencontrre et de
découverte àe ensemble il projettent
d'assister au championnat mondial de ces
si foot en 2016 là on est sur un projet
pour 2016 partir à Rio donc on va on va
faire en sorte de se donner les moyens
pour amener les jeunes à Rio aux jeux
paralympiqu pour qu'ils assissent qu'il
fassent un grand déplacement sur à Paris
et qui puisse aller en fait en métropole
à la même occasion on rencontrera des
clubs brésiliens pour faire des matchs
de City foot et arriver à Paris aussi
faire des matchs contre des équipes de
la de la métropole en fait et Rio ben
c'est une façon de aux jeunes aux
adhérents de notre association de de
voir autre chose de s'ouvrir sur le
monde pas rester sur nous la
Réunion il y a pas que nous quoi en
attendant leur départ ils ont déjà leur
hymne C FOOT 974 prêt à l'emploi tu as
composé un morceau tu m'as dit
[Musique]
pour
ref on ve connaître que ça il est ça
là con à nousmême ça qui ça ramène ça ça
à nousmême
ça
nousê